Hello everyone,
welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the Korean language or
hungle name as it's called in Korean and
actually in North Korea.
It's called Tucson.
My Korean is one of the major languages
of Northeast Asia.
It's spoken as a first language by a
total of around 80 million people,
including around $50 million in South
Korea,
$25 million in North Korea and around
two point 5 million in China,
including the Yom [inaudible] and Chung
back Korean autonomous areas,
which are both in Gelian province near
the border with North Korea.
It's also spoken by minorities in Japan,
Russia,
and numerous other countries throughout
the world.
The roots of the Korean language are
unclear and are the subject of much
debate.
Some think it's a member of the
altruistic language family alongside
Turkic Mongolian and 10 gooseneck and
Japonica languages,
but these days the alltech language
family is no longer widely accepted or
shall we say it's unproven.
Others think that Korean shares ancient
roots with the dravidian languages of
southern India and Sri Lanka,
and there's another theory that Korean
derives from the Austronesian language
family,
but there's no definitive proof for any
of these theories,
so Korean is often defined as a language
isolate.
The sole member of the chorionic
language family.
The lack of evidence for any of these
theories is largely because of the lack
of samples of older Korean writing.
The oldest samples that we are aware of
are less than a thousand years old and
the written in Chinese characters making
them hard to decipher old Korean.
The first century ce marks the beginning
of the three kingdoms period on the
Korean Peninsula and Manchuria the
kingdoms were picked.
J and Sheila.
It's not known for sure just how closely
the languages of these kingdoms were
related.
They may have all been closely related
dialects of old Korean or they may have
been distinct members of the chorionic
language family from limited
information,
mainly place names.
It appears that the languages were
similar but not exactly the same.
There may have been two groups have
chorionic languages with a group
including Pouliot,
Co gooyow and pull your Pec Jay and the
hunting group,
which included Shinola in South Korea.
It's widely believed that Shinola is the
direct ancestor of modern Korean in
North Korea.
It's widely believed that go google is
the direct ancestor of modern Korean.
During the Unified Sheila period,
beginning in the seventh century,
when Sheila conquered the other
kingdoms,
the Shilla variety became the dominant
language of the peninsula.
This is the form of old Korean that
became the ancestor of Middle Korean.
Korea has been tremendously influenced
by China throughout its history due to
invasion attempts,
alliances,
and extensive trade.
The influence on Korean culture includes
stunning influence on the Korean
language.
Since Korean didn't have its own writing
system,
it adopted the Chinese writing system
and used it well into the era of Middle
Korean and a huge amount of Chinese
vocabulary entered Korean through the
literary language,
Middle Korean.
When the Korea Dynasty began in the 10th
century,
the capital moved to case on,
so the case on dialect became the
prestige language.
It seems that by this time the peninsula
basically spoke the same language,
so this was simply a dialectal change.
The first written record of Korean that
we know of beyond place names comes from
this time period,
the sources Chinese and gives a few
hundred examples of Korean words written
phonetically using Chinese characters.
One feature of Middle Korean is that it
featured for tones and on top of that
Chinese loan words still retained their
tones as well.
These tone distinctions have disappeared
in modern standard Korean,
but there are a couple of dialects that
do retain some of these distinctions.
We know that Middle Korean had tones
because there were markings indicating
tone in the hungle writing system,
which was created in 1444 by king say
Joan,
the great of the Chosun Dynasty humble
was created to increase literacy among
the poor and people without a formal
education.
Prior to the creation of hungle Korean
went through a number of different
writing systems that use Chinese
characters in various ways to represent
Korean.
None of which were an ideal match for
Korean or very easy to learn in the
beginning.
Elites and scholars opposed the
introduction of hungle,
but over the following centuries it
became widespread and humble is such an
ingenious writing system that it's
really hard to imagine how it wouldn't
have become widespread for a long time.
Korean was often written and published
in a mixed script using hunch on Chinese
characters for content,
words and hungle for functional or
grammatical words and inflections.
It was quite similar to how Japanese is
still written today.
Speaking of Japanese,
Korea was occupied by Japan from 1910
until 1945.
During the occupation,
Japanese was made.
The official language and policies were
implemented that would have replaced
Korean with Japanese if the occupation
had not been ended.
Japanese was made the language of
education except for Korean class and
speaking Korean at school was band.
Koreans were pressured to replace their
Korean names with Japanese names and
Korean language.
Newspapers were ordered to shut down.
These assimilationist policies were
gradually introduced and speed it up in
the later years of the occupation.
Thankfully,
the Korean language survived to the
occupation,
but a significant amount of Japanese
vocabulary.
It was absorbed into the language in the
decades since the occupation ended.
Hungyo have gradually become
deemphasized in favor of hungle.
Nowadays,
most texts are written entirely or
mostly in hungle with hunch up,
mainly used to prevent possible
ambiguity between homophones and in
North Korea.
Specifically hunch shot were eliminated
from all official publications in 1949.
I'm going to speculate that the growing
emphasis on hungle was partly a reaction
to the Japanese occupation,
that a growing sense of Korean
sovereignty made the Korean people want
to use more of their nations homegrown
script.
The existence of the hungle script is
now every year on hungle day,
October ninth in South Korea and on
chosen Google Day,
January 15th in North Korea.
Both Koreas have a literacy rate of over
99 percent.
So I guess there is reason to celebrate.
So what's Korean like?
Well,
there's a lot to say about Korean and
there's no way I can give a complete
comprehensive overview of the whole
language in a single video,
but we'll look at some of it's important
features.
Hungle hungle is a fantastic writing
system that you can learn to read very
quickly.
There is a basic set of consonant and
vowel symbols that are arranged together
to form compact syllables.
This says hungle this symbolist,
Huh?
This is,
this is,
and this is,
oh,
this system is ingenious.
Because once you get used to the most
common combinations of symbols,
then you can instantly recognize them.
The consonant symbols fall into groups
of different letters.
These continents are vilar,
and the basic shape shows the tongues
position in the mouth.
This point indicates the place of
articulation near the back of the mouth.
These consonants are alveolar and the
basic shape shows the tongue touching
the roof of the mouth.
These consonants are bilabial and the
basic shape shows a mouth with two lips.
These consonants are dentals,
and the basic shape shows the place of
articulation at the upper teeth.
These consonants are glottal,
and the basic shape shows that the place
of articulation is in your throat.
Vocabulary.
In most current examples of written
Korean,
all or almost all of the words are
written in Hungle,
including native Korean words.
And Sign,
oh,
Korean words,
words of Chinese origin,
believe it or not,
sign.
Oh,
Korean words account for over 60 percent
of Korean vocabulary.
There are most prevalent in formal and
academic vocabulary,
but they're very common in everyday
speech as well.
Let's look at the Chinese vocabulary
that appears in the following sentences.
This sentence means,
do you like your teacher?
Some of the same names were.
He'll notice the word sunsetting,
which means teacher.
This word is of Chinese origin.
This sentence means what's your phone
number?
So novel and allowable.
All the words for telephone and number
are of Chinese origin.
When Korean is written in a mixed hungle
hunt,
just script.
You can more easily identify it,
the Sino Korean words,
and you can more easily distinguish
between words that sound the same
because they are written with different
Chinese characters,
but these days they are mainly written
in hungle.
Korean also contains more recent loan
words from other languages,
mainly English words like choose soup,
meaning juice,
poor meaning fork,
send,
do,
eat,
see meaning,
sandwich.
Obviously the pronunciation of these
words has naturally changed and become
suited to Korean phonology.
Some loan words are abbreviated or used
in ways that the original words were not
used.
For example,
the word said con means Selfie,
which came from the words self and
camera.
Another example I usually ping means
window shopping and comes from the words
I and shopping sentence structure.
Korean is a verb,
final language with the verb.
At the end of the sentence,
a typical sentence is Sov.
This sentence means I play baseball.
None in Yagoona Hale.
Here's the subject.
Now here's the object.
Yeah,
Gu,
and here's the verb.
Hail.
It's also possible to say the sentence
with no subject if it's clear from the
context,
but let's go back to the original
sentence for a minute.
In addition to the subject,
object and verb,
there are two other words in the
sentence.
These words are particles.
Words that are placed after nouns to
indicate their function or relationship
to other words in the sentence.
Little is a direct object marker showing
that,
yeah,
Gu baseball is the object of the verb.
A little is the form that follows a word
ending in a vowel.
Oh,
is the form that follows words ending in
a consonant,
noon is a topic marker.
The form that comes afterwards ending in
a consonant is earned,
not is the subject of the sentence,
but it's also the topic that means now
is information that has previously been
mentioned or as clear from the context
and that it's the topic being elaborated
on.
There are also subject markers.
He after a consonant and Qa after a
vowel subject,
markers are used to introduce new
information or to introduce the
importance of existing information.
In other words,
to emphasize it,
we could change the sentence above to
make not the subject.
Degas,
yeah,
I alluded hail,
notice that not is pronounced as nay
when followed by ca and the
pronunciation of changes to God.
In this sentence,
Degas shows that I is the new
information or emphasized information.
This might be said in response to a
question asking who plays baseball in
English.
We might stress this subject like I play
baseball.
Here's another example of when you might
use the subject marker.
This sentence means my mother entered
the room.
Actually,
this part literally means our mother,
but it's used to mean my when referring
to your own ingroup.
Anyway,
in this case,
my mother is new information because
before that she wasn't present,
she wasn't in the room,
so the subject particle is suitable.
Here,
this word here a is another particle
showing direction,
like the English preposition to or into,
but technically speaking,
since the particle comes after the Noun,
it's a post position rather than a
preposition.
In Korean modifiers come before the
things that they modify.
That means that adjectives come before
nouns.
Dual pins on this means a tall mountain.
This is the word for tall and this is
the word for mountain.
This part connects the adjective to the
gnome.
Longer modifiers also come before the
noun.
You want them to modify it.
This phrase means the mountain.
I want to climb.
Degas,
older bullshit.
Pleasanton,
word for word.
This phrase is I subject marker.
Climb,
want connector mountain.
But if we take the whole modifying
clause,
a single unit,
this modifier plus Noun pattern is like
saying the,
I want to climb the mountain.
So whereas in English,
the modifier would come after the nouns.
In Korean,
it comes before.
By the way,
this sentence could mean a mountain.
I want to climb with indefinite meaning.
Korean doesn't have definite or
indefinite articles.
So definiteness can be understood from
context verbs and adjectives.
Every sentence in Korean must end in
either a verb or an adjective,
and verbs and adjectives act very
similar to each other in Korean,
with both being conjugated,
for pastor,
non past and for different politeness
levels.
First,
let's look at verbs.
The dictionary form of verbs all end in
de,
for example,
this verb meaning to stop and this verb
meaning to sleep.
In order to conjugate these verbs,
you remove and you are left with the
verb stem which you add affixes to.
So let's conjugate these verbs in the
present tense or non past tense.
To be precise.
This sentence means he stops eating
coonamble d'amato.
So look at how we conjugate the verb to
stop the stem is model.
The informal,
present tense ending is ah,
and the polite suffix is your.
So this is the informal,
polite conjugation for verb stems,
whose final vowel sound is awful,
or Oh,
this verb ends in a consonant,
but when the verb ends in a vowel,
then only you'll is added.
For example,
Coonan's Hale,
he sleeps notes that with either of
these verbs you could remove your to
make an informal non polite sentence.
In other words,
a more casual sentence.
If the stem ends in it's replaced with
audio.
Here's an example with the verb meaning
to try and sit down.
Could do it.
In this sentence means they try.
If the last vegetable of the stem is all
or eat or a combined vowel,
then or are y'all,
is added to the stem.
Look down again,
we have the verb meaning to eat.
Non In this sentence means I eat pogie.
Let's take a look at how the past tense
is formed by changing some of those
sentences into the past.
Before we had this sentence,
Cunanan look on io,
meaning he stops eating.
Let's change this to.
He stopped eating in the past Coonan
sale.
He Sleeps Coonan tail,
he slept coconut soil.
Let's remove the polite suffix,
your for a moment.
Notice that the past tense form equals
the present tense form with this affix
saw attached then to make it polite,
we can add your future tense.
Korean technically doesn't have a future
tense,
only passed and non passed,
but there are ways to express the
future,
the most common being,
the probable future for them.
To use the probable future form,
you add a little cardio to the verb
stem.
None in this sentence means I'm going to
eat Takagi.
When talking about things aside from
yourself,
the probable future refers to things
that you think are likely to happen,
but when referring to yourself,
it shows determination rather than
speculation.
So we can translate this as I'm going to
eat typography or I shall eat meat.
By the way,
I'm probably pronouncing this word to
you,
the way it's pronounced in Japanese.
I live in Japan,
so I've eaten a lot more top pogie here
than in Korea.
Adjectives when an adjective is in the
predicative position,
in other words,
after the subject,
then it functions similarly to a verb
and is conjugated.
Honeydew Pio,
the sentence means the mountain is tall,
the present tense,
affix and polite affix are added to the
adjective stem,
just like a verb,
and we can make this past tense to
honeymoon.
Paso,
the mountain was tall.
This is conjugated,
just like the past tense verb speech
levels.
When looking at verbs in the previous
section,
we looked mainly at the informal polite
forms of verbs like Mateo from my Ada
and I briefly mentioned that we could
make the informal non polite form by
removing your like Mata.
These are two of seven politeness levels
and Korean.
Luckily for learners,
not all,
seven of them are commonly used,
three or maybe four are commonly used.
The other two are formal,
polite,
Manzanita,
and formal,
non polite Munda.
The informal polite form is used when
speaking to friends and acquaintances.
Colleagues have a similar status to you,
shop staff,
et Cetera.
The informal non polite form is used
when speaking to very close friends,
a brother or sister,
someone a few years younger than you or
someone you want to be rude to.
The formal polite form is used when
speaking to someone of higher status
than you and people you are meeting for
the first time.
The formal non polite form is basically
a neutral forum that you can use when
you don't know who the reader or
listener is.
In other words,
when you're speaking to many types of
people,
it can also be used in speaking to
friends of the same age range.
Let's look at a couple more sentences in
Korean and see what we find.
This sentence means I have a bicycle but
I don't have a car.
None in has he been tackled so word for
word it's I topic marker,
Bicycle Subject Marker.
There is,
but car subject marker.
There isn't.
This sentence shows us how to express
possession or have in Korean.
The topic of the sentence is the
possessor.
Then the thing that is possessed is the
subject of the sentence with a subject
marker followed by the existence verb
meaning there is or there are.
Then we start a new sentence with but
and there is a subject car with a
subject marker followed by the negative
verb of existence.
Meaning there isn't or there aren't.
Notice that there's no topic in the
second sentence.
The topic can be skipped if it's already
clear.
Another sentence.
This means this food is delicious.
Did you cook it?
You Michigan?
Less so the word for word,
it's this food topic marker,
delicious,
informal,
polite,
conjugation.
You subject,
marker.
Cooking did informal,
non polite conjugation.
This first sentence follows a very
common pattern.
Here's the subject which is also the
topic of the sentence with a topic
marker and before the known we can see
the demonstrative.
He meaning this and here we have the
adjective which is conjugated like a
verb.
In the second sentence,
the subject is the word for you,
followed by the subject marker.
Ca Yodlee is the word for cooking or
cuisine,
and [inaudible] is the verb.
Meaning do conjugated in the past tense,
informal,
non polite form.
This is the same as the informal polite
form with the syllable you'll removed
from the end of both sentences when
talking directly to someone.
It's very common to drop the subject.
Pronouns,
for example,
God is so,
but in this case,
the subject and subject marker ca are
included to emphasize you like did you
cook it as opposed to someone else?
Next,
we see something very common and
important.
In Korean,
we have a verb that consists of two
parts,
unknown of Chinese origin,
followed by the verb,
which means to do or to make.
Many,
many Korean verbs are constructed this
way.
For example,
Eda meaning to work,
meaning to study.
There are also some words of English
origin that form verbs.
This way,
for example,
how will have meaning to shower.
Let's look at one last sentence.
Can you tune this sentence means she is
a good student word for word,
it's she topic marker.
Good connector student.
Be Informal,
polite.
So here we have the subject which is
also the topic with a topic marker.
Then we have the adjective meaning good,
and since it comes before the gnome,
there's a connector.
Huck saying means student and the verb
is at the end.
This verb is the informal polite form of
EDA,
which basically means to be and usually
comes after nouns.
There's also a negative form of this
verb,
Anita,
so we could make this sentence negative
like this Cunanan swoon.
Now the sentence means she is not a good
student.
Noticed that in the negative form of
this sentence,
the subject marker,
he comes after us saying,
so with this particular verb,
you have the topic and then the
compliment actually becomes the subject
of the sentence.
There's really so much more I could say
about Korean and there's no way I can
cover everything in a single video,
but hopefully that gave you a taste of
the language and sparked your interest.
In some ways,
Korean is strikingly similar to
Japanese,
but in some ways it's quite different.
You might want to check out my video
from a couple of years ago on the
differences and similarities between
Korean and Japanese.
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and Instagram,
and once again,
thank you to all of my wonderful patrion
supporters,
especially my top tier patrion
supporters right here on the screen.
Many thanks to them and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.